a man was a star of NCIS only lassie and
Gunsmoke have been on CBS for more
seasons than NCIS which is in its 15th
season good to see you Mark Harmon same
right lassie and Gunsmoke yeah there's
some company that's that's a pretty
respectable neighborhood when it comes
down to that I mean what do you think of
when you hear about the fact that you've
been on the same TV show for 15 years
and what was the number that we just
mentioned number of episodes that we
just talked about read 350 450
yeah no it's it's it's rare air
certainly and and it doesn't feel like
as long as it's been but but it's it's
still it's still fun still new things
there I like the people I get to work
with every day right I like being there
what's the strangest foreign language
you've seen your show in NCIS you know
uh probably Russian okay yeah all right
and you never like the guy who is
poisoning yeah right and yeah but but
this this this show actually caught on
internationally quicker than it did here
so yeah and and when you you know in
season five or six when you went to do
publicity and got out of the country
then all of a sudden you realize it was
a little more difficult to walk down the
street than it was here so did you
always want to get into acting I mean
when you were let's say when you were
know suiting up for you CLO and on the
cleats playing quarterback the Rose Bowl
no no no no I I just I wanted to take
pride in doing something and working
hard at it every day that's kind of how
I grew up watching my dad and I I had a
bunch of different starts you know I was
I did a lot of different jobs and like
what I I sold shoes I was in law school
for a little bit I you know when was
that when you were you selling shoes
while you were playing quarterback for
UCLA no no after I worked for adidas for
about eight months and before that I had
it was in
merchandising and radio here in Los
Angeles and then I was studying acting
all the time during the nighttime but
but for a few years after college other
than being carpenter I was just trying
to do whatever I could do to make a few
bunk huh
so did you never have any pro prospects
at the NFL ever come knocking on your
door I had a chance to go to camp which
camp I had calls from New England I had
AFL the CFL they were all in full swing
at the time and and I had chances to go
and go to camp there too but I know I
just never it was never even something I
thought about it was just it was time to
move on to something else and this ended
up being it what I mean did you not want
do i when you do something as long as
you do something like that right and
it's always hard to say goodbye to it
but I I never I never had aspirations
for that I I played with a lot of guys
who did 22 guys off the team I played on
went on to some sort of a pro career
some of them were shorter than others
what was the best I guess that you UCLA
Jimmy Allen maybe you know Kermit
Johnson James McAllister those guys all
had Randy cross those guys all had big
bigger Pro careers and some others who
was your coach at the time at the time
it was pepper Rogers my position coach
was Homer Smith and this was just prover
meal there you see it was yeah ok yeah 1
year before so it's interesting Mark
Harmon you're in the Rich Eisen show
because the conversation about the
current UCLA quarterback going to the
next level mm-hmm Josh Rosen have you
ever met him never okay but the the
conversation about him is that he has
too many interests other than football
in the same way that you you obviously
were not somebody that was all about
football which is fascinating since your
dad we had a terrific football life so
what do you think when you hear that
Josh Rosen might not be a quality
professional or a top pick because he
might have other interests I think
that's kind of up to Josh Rosen you know
and I think people judge and people have
opinions and that's the right I guess
but
you know it's a lot different for the
person taking the snap you know from
where he stands and for what is ahead
for him and what his goals are and what
he's wanted to do for maybe all his life
I think he's in a pretty good position
and and I look forward to seeing what
next year is for him and and and how
he'll accomplish that dream so many have
that dream and so few have an
opportunity and he'll certainly get that
opportunity so I just hope it's in a in
a place and where the coaching staff
where he doesn't get hit as much as even
hit the last couple yes I know and and
and the beating that he has taken
sometimes two meters that he he's a guy
who wants it not just the fact that he
he has it because I guess he's doing it
as a hobby it's kind of crazy Mark
Harmon here on the show because to me
again just because he has other
interests just because he asks why
instead of says okay to me means he
wants to be collaborative did you ever
ask why something is sure all the time
of your coaches you know we were running
what was the relatively new offense and
so asking questions was part of how you
learned it you know and like I said my
position coaches Homer Smith and he was
a guy that early on that's the only way
you learned is to ask questions and the
only way you learned is to make mistakes
you sometimes you learn so much more
from mistakes and break from something
that's good but I just think that's
about growth I don't I don't find a harm
in that and I don't I you know I think
it's very easy to be critical and have
an opinion which is you're right but
believe me it just looks a lot different
from where he's standing right you know
and and you watch a game on a Saturday
from your living room
and you see a quarterback throw ball and
hit it hit a free safety right in the
chest with the ball and go come on I
could do better than that I said well I
guarantee you it looks much different
from where he's standing from where you
are right and and and I think that that
has to do with people who have played
and people who haven't and there's a big
difference what's the hardest you ever
been hit what's that what's the hardest
you've ever been hit oh I don't know
about hardest I I just I just know
that the step up from from you know from
Pop Warner to high school from high
school to college was extreme and and
and the speed was an extreme difference
and and that's what what I think most
about I don't know that actually the the
impact was what I thought about but but
we ran the wishbone so I could hit a lot
that was part of the offense so you know
I don't think I think I probably got hit
more than Josh did but but he got hit
plenty and hopefully in the next level
you won't because I mean you've always
done your own stunts - no no no it does
not there's a thing called stuntmen and
they say they're really good at what
they do and so I'm really eager to step
aside that's their job it's in Westwood
we're not even that sadena I did I look
at it like it's taking the job away from
somebody else so I don't try to take
people's job look at you you're a team
player there is no I in Mark Harmon
that's what he's basically saying there
is a nine NCIS we'll talk in 60 seconds
we come back a little bit about
tonight's game okay I'm wondering if you
have a rooting interest in tonight's
game any way shape or form
sure like maybe we're back at 60 seconds
of Mark Harmon and we'll also talk about
this piece of lumber that I have right
here bat that's got the name Billy Wyatt
on it we're back here on the Rich Eisen
show in 60 seconds
[Music]
Mark Harmon back here on the rich
Johnson show again and NCIS every single
Tuesday including tomorrow night at 8:00
Eastern Time we've seen all the promos
for NCIS during the NCAA tournament when
there's two shooting free-throws they
say hey tuning innocent Tuesday night is
it safe to assume in tonight's game
again you're a Michigan man would you
consider yourself a Michigan man outside
of a UCLA I'm the son of a Michigan man
okay I don't know so you're kinda okay
man I grew up with the maize and blue
and look I know you have a background
there and I do I went to school there so
are you do you have a rooting interest
in tonight's game sure I'd love to see
Michigan win but I I think I think being
there is is a great honor and and that
doesn't it's not that's not too great
for the team that comes in second place
sure that you race I did know that in my
life Villanova fans watch NCIS too it's
another way I know I'm not even talking
like that I just I I kind of like the
underdog a little bit and so you were
also the voice of the narrator of the
new season of All or Nothing on the
Michigan Wolverines Friday April 6th is
when it starts streaming exclusively on
Amazon Prime video
what was your what's your memory of the
big house any good memories from the
from the big house I was there I was
there when they they honored my dad and
my wife is from Michigan so the first
time she had ever been to the big house
was that night and we were down the
field they were playing Notre Dame quite
an event spectacular to be on the field
for that night mm-hmm
so I I had been there before but but
that night was really special then
probably because it was about my dad
mourn it was about me yeah first Heisman
Trophy winner in the history of Michigan
yeah
you ever meet Bo Schembechler I did he
recruited me hold on a second bo
Schembechler recruits the son of Tom
Harmon and the son of Tom Harmon goes to
UCLA right I mean walk me through that
mark I was I was looking for an
opportunity to play you know and and and
an opportunity to study what I wanted to
study and
and I think for me the fit was probably
better at UCLA my dad my dad stayed
totally out of it
he did yeah totally um when you told him
I don't want to go to Michigan oh my and
say that I just said I almost went to
Oklahoma and then and then ended up
going to UCLA and and I think for me for
a lot of different reasons and certainly
some of those reasons were 20 years down
the line I knew nothing about that at
the time but uh for me it was the right
play
so Switzer almost gotcha Switzer was it
Chuck Fairbanks and Switzer was the
offensive coordinator yeah okay so why'd
you almost go to Oklahoma instead they
you know Jack Miller is running around
the wishbone and like every other kid I
grew up watching him and and I knew I
was gonna be running a triple option
offense if I was gonna be playing
quarterback so to be recruited by them
at that time and certainly meet Jack and
have him be your host for a couple days
in Norman that was pretty daunting
I would say yeah Switzer was he crazy
he's like a fox at the time to vote
certainly crazy okay I like I do like
him okay and then it's interesting cuz
Aikman had a year and before he went to
UCLA do you have a relationship with
Troy I've met him his [ __ ] as we all
did a photo once a bunch easily
quarterbacks like over a 20-year span
all came for a photograph yeah
opportunity and there were a bunch of
you know basically six foot six foot one
guys
and then there was Troy who looks like a
defensive end
I mean he's big he's a tall strong so
obviously a drop back Pro style versus
the option guys that I was part of so
Mark Harmon here on the show once again
which I'm always appreciative of you
coming back to chat about real please
anytime last time you were here you said
you know what there's a couple of uh
Billy Wyatt baseball bats that exist
I've got one and I want to send it to
you well you told me your wife like the
movies well she yes I mean look it to me
most most people love stealing home if
not everybody it's just it is
a it's a universally loved film and a
lot of women really fell in love not
just with the movie but with you and I
think my wife might have been one of
them rich the last thing I do is walk
around trying to give away Billy white
at baseball bats so I know which is very
appreciative I have it right here here
it is
I'd like to hand it to you do what just
don't hold it and say okay no basically
and just to put a billy white baseball
bat back in your hands what are you what
are your memories I remember that there
were only 12 of these made okay and and
like I said I had a couple and now I
have one as yours thank you I appreciate
I'd like to sign it but sure what why do
you think the movie resonated and still
does you know I only know from being an
actor and knowing the two guys will all
this and Steve Kampmann who who wrote
produced and also directed co-directed
then that that movie and I just know
that it was a script that hit me like it
hit everybody who's in that movie and we
all tested for it including Jody I mean
everybody did and I and I I just think
it was one of those movies you do
because you love the material and it was
a tough shoot we all worked hard we all
carried lights and did everything else
we had to do to make it happen no
kidding yeah Jodie Foster was carrying
lights yeah she was she was part of it
it was all all for one I'm really a team
effort and it's one of those movies that
you know good bad people like it don't
like it whatever I just impart of that
experience universally loved it really
nice to know it really is I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention the passing of
Steven Bochco yeah not to you thank you
well I mean he meant a lot to me
personally he's been on the show a
couple of times and you wrote a book
well he wrote he he he wrote a memoir
that I was kind of he was kind enough to
accept my offer to interview him for it
yeah I know but that's Steven Bochco
asking you to do that it was really
special it was really great yeah it was
really great oh I'd love to give you the
floor and like did you ever come across
him oh yeah no we've him I met
Stevan many times and read for him many
times didn't get one part from him but
but it he is also you know in a weird
way responsible for how I ended up doing
st. elsewhere because I was I was
constantly up for a show he was doing
called bass City Blues baseball jewelry
and and I had been back to meet him time
and time again five six times maybe and
and I was walking down the hallway after
the last meeting and the casting
director was the same for saying
elsewhere and at the time Hill Street
Blues and he said you know they're
trying to cast this plastic surgeon on
this hospital show saying elsewhere and
would you like to read for that well as
long as you're here and I went in I read
for Bruce Paltrow cold and in the
reading it's never happened before or
since he said hey that was that was good
I like it you want to do it you got it
so I called my agent and I said I said
we're gonna get an offer to do this and
they said Bay City Blues that's great
and I said no this other show called st.
elsewhere because it's down down the
hallway and I ended up in that meeting
as well and so that's the one we're
gonna get it go on and but I I would run
into Steven we were in the same
basically the same building same sound
stages roughly at MTM they're always a
nice guy always always an innovative guy
and and and in so many ways responsible
for so many careers not not only actors
but writers and producers and and a
whole change of the the system and the
way things were going at the time and
saying elsewhere was would you say that
I'm just obviously your first big break
of your career correct yes first time
first like you know major ensemble piece
that I ever did all of a sudden you're
you've got better words to say and
you're working with better actors or
different actors and the opportunity
changes and and I was fortunate to have
that job well I really appreciate you
coming by here again you're always
welcome here appreciate it
anytime and NCIS check it out every
single Tuesday at 8:00 Eastern Time 15th
season with Mark Harmon thanks for
coming on such a rich you got it you bet
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience